but first it's my me grain dump
well parties are often
followed by a massive hangover you know
the score a spilling headache that just
won't go away
flimsy groveling excuses for the
embarrassments of the night before
perhaps a dash of nausea perhaps even a
dash of remorse
well partygate the illegal lockdown
busting scandal that engulfed boris
johnson's conservative government has
now turned into a six-month hangover
from hell for the beleaguered and
notably remorseless prime minister and
the excuses of the last remaining boris
bros are sounding increasingly desperate
it was a work to that's what people do
at work but it wasn't a crime and i
don't believe that it was a party
well it was a crime because at least one
person got fined by the police for being
there and it was a party or they
wouldn't have been fined for being at an
illegal party and that's what he says
about that's what people do at work
does desmond swain work in a nightclub
well here's his colleague peter bone
you might want it to be a party but
unless you're going to say that the
prime minister he's not telling the
truth and the met police aren't telling
the truth it wasn't a party
it was a party mr bone you can only
assume you don't get invited to many of
them if you did then you might have
discovered that raising a toast
surrounded by four bottles of wine two
bottles of champagne and a bottle of gin
very much resembles a party
grant shacks the cabinet minister who's
always wheeled out to defend the
indefensible insisted that johnson was
clearly not partying even though he was
clearly partying and then he added this
i think it's probably worth
recalling in context that throughout
this period the prime minister himself
had been seriously ill had a close brush
with coronavirus he lost his mum during
the period he's dealing with the
pandemic
but he didn't lose his mum in that
period in fact boris johnson's mother
charlotte johnson wall died 10 months
after the party happened
some people are saying we should move on
from all this
but we shouldn't this scandal goes to
the heart of the prime minister's
credibility and integrity the times
reported today that boris johnson
suggested to civil servant sue gray the
very woman investigating him that she
should drop her inquiry in that secret
meeting two weeks ago but number ten
said was all her idea before admitting
that they'd lied about that too and it
was their idea this is the kind of
behavior that mafia bosses get up to
when they're trying to intimidate
investigators the slow trickle of
damning evidence has turned into a
relentless torrent of sleaze boris
johnson has become a gigantic national
headache and increasingly it looks like
the only cure will be his departure
well there have been a few more
sickening videos this year than the one
showing premier league football star
kurt zuma brutally kicking and slapping
his pet cat around the kitchen as he
sneered i swear i'll kill it here it is
[Laughter]
we're unable to see that video because
his brother johan filmed the whole thing
he said he thought it was really funny
posting it on snapchat with laughing
emojis well today justice had the last
laugh on these sniveling little cowards
as zoomer pleaded guilty to causing
suffering to protect an animal and his
equally vile brother admitted aiding and
abetting him the zuma was fined as 250
000 pounds by his club west ham united
which given he earns 6 million pounds a
year is a pathetically ineffective slap
on the wrist that he'll barely have
noticed if zuma had done this to a woman
he'd never played professional football
again
why should he get away with doing it to
a defenseless cat
well sometimes these stories are so
shocking they become where were you
moments images so vivid or moving you
can recall exactly what you were doing
when you stopped in your tracks and saw
them the shambolic withdrawal of u.s and
british forces in afghanistan last
summer sadly provided several of those
moments he will never forget the videos
of men desperately clinging onto a u.s
military plane or the afghan mothers
throwing their babies desperately to
soldiers
so where was dominic raab the british
foreign secretary when this all happened
well he was on holiday in crete
and how about sir philip barton the boss
of the british foreign office well he
was on holiday too in france and that's
where he stayed until after the
evacuation was over
both of these men are still serving the
british government a foreign affairs
committee report into the withdrawals
they tore into the british role in that
exit calling it a disaster which cost
lives and abandoned the afghan people to
the taliban's evil clutches it also
rightly slammed both of those foreign
office leaders for being missing in
action as kabul fell
the cowardly chaos of the u.s exit made
president biden look weak unbelievable
and heartless we now know the british
government was no better shame on them
one of the biggest problems for young
people today is fomo the fear of missing
out the fear of missing out on parties
on fun on smashed avocados for brunch
and most of all the fear of missing out
looking like their dream idols on
instagram hundreds of millions of young
girls now want to be and look like for
reasons that completely baffle me the
kardashians
but the heart of fomo is fake
what they're in fear of missing out on
usually doesn't even exist the
kardashians are the global flag bearers
for photographic fakery as evidenced
again by courtney's wedding to travis
barker talk about instagram versus
reality look at this
these people just aren't real here is
courtney kardashian on instagram and
here's how she actually looked over the
weekend
even these apparently world-beating
beauties don't look the way they make
you think they do here's khloe
kardashian her sister on instagram
and here's chloe as she actually looked
at the weekend it's all an illusion of
perfection every time they post these
pictures online to their millions of
followers they're just pulling another
contract to burnish their brand to the
world here's kylie jenner on instagram
versus kylie as she looked at the
weekend now look here's the point i'd
make they all look absolutely fine to
start with
they don't need to do all this frenzied
airbrushing to seek a bogus perfection
so don't fear missing out on looking
like the kardashians because they don't
look like the
kardashians you see pictures of your
dream boats on instagram well i'm afraid
you just can't believe what you're
seeing
they just don't correspond to reality
why do you say what have you put up
there
i don't get that